second time in a week There's a tipped
over big rig that has completely shut
down a freeway earlier this week it was
the Northbound i-11 at Wagon Wheel right
now it's the Northbound I-15 before you
get to the northern 215 Beltway show you
what we're talking about here no idea
why we're having tipped over big rigs
but we do have a complete freeway
closure now there are a lot of folks who
were backed up at the scene they got off
a Tropical Parkway and I'm no traffic
engineer but it seems to be easier to
let folks off a Tropical Parkway but
what they're doing now is shutting down
the north 15 at lamb so to continue on
the North 15 here's what you have to do
you have to get off at lamb take that
all the way up to the 215 then take the
215 back to the 15. now we have our own
photographer on scene at this crash and
this is some of the diversion there on
the 15 before you get to Tropical
Parkway and before you're getting off
there at lamb it is going to be a real
nightmare back to the traffic shooter we
go to show you the look of the traffic
computer and the traffic cameras on
scene we're told this closure could last
until 10 or 11 o'clock this morning this
is going to be a huge backup the tipped
over big rig Northbound on the I-15
before the 215 Beltway sitting right
there across all Lanes of traffic that's
the ramp that takes you from the north
15 to the westbound 215 Northern Beltway
we'll try to find out more and keep you
posted we can find out more about the
weather right now for sure